good afternoon welcome thank you very
much for coming
my name is Paul Eli I'm an author and
senior fellow with the Berkeley Center
for religion peace and world affairs
here at Georgetown and I'm very pleased
to welcome today
Pankaj Mishra for a conversation about
his new book age of anger a few words
about Pankaj I'll because Mishra is one
of the most accomplished acclaimed and
versatile writers working in English
today Warren in Northwest India in 1969
he lives in London writes and reports
from London India and points worldwide
it's a contributor to the New York of
your book The New Yorker near Times
magazine Bloomberg view the London of
your books Financial Times and plenty of
other publications his books include the
novel of romantics set in Banaras an end
to suffering the Buddha in the world the
novel I've had the privilege to teach my
courses here at Georgetown temptations
of the West from the ruins of Empire
from 2012 that book led the economist to
characterize Mishra as a leading Indian
public intellectual who with a
surprising new perspective the air as
recited the Turkish novelist nobel
laureate Orhan Pamuk called the book the
amazing stories of the grandfather's of
today's angry Asians the novelist motion
Hamid author of The Reluctant
Fundamentalist chose it as one of his
books of the year in the Financial Times
that book won the crossroad award for
the best non-fiction in 2013 and in 2014
became the first book by a non-western
writer to win Germany's prestigious
Leipzig Book Award for European
understanding was also shortlisted for
the Lionel Gelber award for the world's
best non-fiction book in English on
Foreign Affairs for the Orwell prize
Britain's most prestigious prize for
political writing for the Asian
societies British Ward's book award the
new book age of anger
history of the present is canonical
already if you asked me books reviewer
called it the first essential read of
the trump era John Banville the novelist
put it this way Pankaj Mishra follows
the likes of Isaiah Berlin John Gray
mark wheeler by delving into the past in
order to throw light on our contemporary
predicament the neglected and
dispossessed of the world have suddenly
risen up Ameche in' resentiment
to transform the world we thought we
knew Pankaj Mishra is a member of the
Royal Society of literature it's a great
honor to have him have you as a guest
conversation here at Georgetown thank
you very much for coming frankish thank
you both so at the very front of the new
book you describe the circumstance which
you began to write it in 2014 after
friends and family members of yours in
India like Hindu nationalist power and
that your effort to write the book
coincided with angry emergent
nationalisms in India and in other
places can you tell us a little bit how
that came about and what it was like to
write a book of let's say intellectual
history running in parallel to current
events in the president booth wasn't
strange experience and if you say it was
provoked by the election victory of
Narendra Modi in 2014 a man that many of
us in India thought should be in prison
who had really many of us thought had
been utterly disgraced by conduct on
different occasions in the past and
suddenly you know come into power with
lots of people including members of my
own family voting for him this is now an
experience common to all of us around
the world
which divided families and it really
forced me to examine some of my own
assumptions assumptions that I had never
really in a way investigated such as a
belief in democracy a belief in
democracy producing a moral outcome and
suddenly I thought well you know this is
democracy has produced a kind of moral
calamity in this instance so what is
this thing that I've believed in for so
long what are these ideals these
abstractions these concepts that I've
unconsciously embrace for so long so it
really sort of you know made me go much
deeper than than any other political
event any other event in the past 20
years since I've been writing and I felt
I had to sort of move away from
journalism as it was it had to go you
know somewhere deeper and also examine
increased by I mean brought my framework
and sort of including its events
personalities that had on the face of it
very little to do with India but to
which India and events in India were
intimately connected so the 19th century
for instance the fate of the Russians
trying to catch up with with with the
Atlantic West and similar such
experiences and some of those
experiences already written about in my
previous book which is from the ruins of
empire
about Japan trying to do the same trying
to catch up importing ideologies ideas
from from the modern West and then
sparking kind of rush to imitation
amongst various other Asian countries
but this involves really going deeper
into European history and looking at
people who had also come late to the
modern world countries like in many ways
resembling the Indian elites the Indian
intelligence here who had produced all
kinds of figures with you know the great
desire to match the achievements of the
modern West and you know that is what's
in we had grown up with in India those
ideas those ideas and I felt I had to
really go back and consider them all the
book is built on a large and very solid
historical parallel essentially that the
history of let's say the 125 years
before the outbreak of World War one was
world by industrial capitalism in the so
called developed world and that the
responses of different figures and then
of social movements in that time if you
look at them it can give us an idea of
how to understand similar developments
and social movements happening now on a
global scale as more countries face
industrial capitalism and are introduced
into global commerce and so forth what
point of that that big comparison
between one century and another European
history and global history coming to
view or did it not come into view with
that clarity you had to develop well
there are certain genealogies that have
always been evidence for instance Hindu
nationalism which is triumphant in India
right now
connections with German and Italian
fascism with the Nazis and the fascists
have been written about so we know that
these ideologies have traveled around
the world and assumed very different
forms but share certain similar ideas
certain similar commitments but I think
this book or writing this book made me
think that perhaps we have to go even
further not to stop at the 1930s look at
the 19th century look at the experience
of people who were trying to as I said
catch up with the modern West and at the
same time struggling with the political
pathologies unleashed by this attempt to
catch up so you embrace industrial
capitalism you adopt the nation-state
the model of the nation-state for your
heterogeneous very diverse societies and
then you start struggling with the
problems thereby unleashed by this this
process of adoption and adaptation and
you know so far we've been writing about
I've been I've been writing about how
this process played itself out in Asia
and Africa but for this I felt I had to
now go back and look at Germany in the
early 19th century acid face the
increasing wealth and power and
sophistication of its neighbors its
immediate neighbors and also indeed a
military and political challenge from
them our Germany or german-speaking
peoples and lands first responded to
this enormous challenge from the West
which was economic which is military
which was intellectual which was
cultural and you know those feelings
also of being disdained being scorned
being actually humiliated in a military
campaign and then having this man who
occupies your country Napoleon mocking
and scorning your cause
all those that this particular kind of
cultural instruction which we see early
on in the 19th century which then we see
replicate itself across vast tracts of
Asia and Africa as modern imperialism
spreads so again I mean I felt this is
really a kind of global framework that
we have to consider all these
experiences within the framework of the
modern the modern which begins
essentially in the late 18th century
that's when the principles of the modern
world are formulated that's when the
world we live in starts to come into
being that's when the most radical
projects in human history which is the
modern project is institutionalized and
ante arised so you know that sort of
really explains why I just couldn't stop
even in the 19th century auditorially go
back to the to the beginnings of this
supose emancipation from the past from
tradition from custom from traditional
hierarchy from religious authority from
the monarchy all those Liberation's that
were exhorted that were advocated back
then and then actually then started to
happen all through the 19th century and
are still happening for many people
around the words there one of the key
points you make is that members of
Islamic state and terrorists and violent
nationalists in Asia in the Middle East
have Western roots can you explain that
well I think it's not so much Western
roots its modern roots I'm very much
distrustful of these very ambitious
genealogies that locate the roots of
militant violence for instance in
something that was said in the 13th
century or 15th century I mean generally
creating the roots of militant violence
or terrorism in a particular religion is
really a catastrophic mistake it is
ignoring the long history of terrorism
within the modern West which starts as I
described in the books in the late 19th
century with anarchists terrorists with
Russians with people in Spain and Italy
indeed in the United States and these
people their religion is not the most
important thing about them and I think
since 9/11 we've consistently made this
mistake of identifying terrorism or
militant disaffection with a particular
religious community and particularly
religious and a particular religion and
come up with all kinds of harebrained
theories about how we should reform
Islam or let's help the moderates win
their battle is against the extremism in
all these kind of bizarre theories and
we are now realizing postback suppose
Trump that a lot of pathologies that we
identified exclusively with Muslim
countries they have they can spring up
anywhere they have sprung up in all
kinds of in all parts of you will
irrespective of what the local religion
is or what the local culture is and they
can spring up whenever the conditions
are presents whenever the conditions of
that possibility are there it takes a
little bit of economic decline it takes
a little bit of you know the experience
of humiliation and and deprivation for
those pathologies to be reanimated they
always lie there under the surface and
you know with Muslim countries many of
them you're looking at essentially
absolutely devastated societies failed
States it's not surprising at all that
they would generate these young men
these these figures who just you know
want to go out and kill a lot of people
and and join various death guards we've
seen this over and over again as I say
in this book in in just the last 100
hundred 50 years there is nothing at all
Islamic about this so you say that we've
come to understand that the these
figures don't have essentially religious
motivations or roots but you've known
that all along I've known you for 12
years and you've been saying it as long
as I've known you but what we have in
the new book is a synthesis or an
historical account for or a
counter-narrative to this narrative that
you've been tilting against really in
all your work since since 9/11 let's say
is that the case or is this these are
things you've believed all along but I
have just managed to find the right
shape or pattern for but there is no way
I could not believe that I mean growing
up in India with all kinds of extremist
political ideologies that were again not
exclusively located could not be
exclusively located in the Muslim
community or the Muslim population there
were Hindu extremists there were Sikh
extremists you looked around the
neighborhood I've just returned from
from spending month in Myanmar where you
have Buddhist monks who are ethnic
lenses how does one explain that I mean
you know is there a Buddhist text out
there with sanctions violence against
the infidels maybe there is you know
some some obscure texts somewhere in
some Tibetan monastery I'm sure you can
find it but what would that prove the
reason why even Buddhists have resorted
to ethnic cleansing and extreme forms of
violence lodges in Myanmar or Thailand
Sri Lanka other places as well has been
little to do with with with with
religion or religious texts it has to do
with certain very specific
socio-economic factors and we have to
investigate we have to analyze and
standards and this is something I've
been saying over and over again you know
based upon my experience of these these
particular realities I mean in many ways
I mean we have been dealing we have been
exchanging intellectual crudities for a
long time and you know people constantly
try to argue with me saying you know why
is it that most terrorists seemed to
come from Muslim countries I said you
know just just think about this question
why is it that so much violence in the
first half of 20th century was committed
by Europeans why do they slaughter each
other in the way that it millions and
tens of millions of people killed is
anything peculiar to Europe is anything
peculiar to Christianity do you think
and when you phrase it that way how
incredibly crude that question is how
ignorant really of you know release
against specific economic social
cultural political realities but this is
how we've been thinking about violence
and in the world today the way you put
it in the book is that people thinking
about the Western narrative the Western
narrative of progress are able to put
into a box the exceptions to the idea of
progress to horrible world wars and
plenty of violent imperialist adventures
and so forth all those things are boxed
as the exceptions and that enables the
person promoting this narrative to say
that it's essentially a narrative of
progress and what you're saying is you
can't put those things in the box the
problems that we're seeing today on a
global scale essentially enable us to
see the problems that have been around
with industrial capitalism all along
well I mean I suppose that was the
problem that was the problem at the end
of history narrative is that it really
in a way undermined critical faculties
it diminished our historical imagination
because in many ways the period that's
just come to an end
the post 1945 period was Tony Judt
called it
ventus's and in a long history of
violence and conflict which starts in in
the nineteenth century and we were
blinded to this history by our faith and
his substitute religion of universal
progress and in this instance defined as
the global spread of liberal democracy
and capitalism and we became steadily
unaware of this large tormented history
of the modern world
where efforts to modernize to embrace
these new ideologies of progress of
modernization invariably caused
incredible conflicts trauma suffering
uprooted not millions of people being
uprooted moving to large cities where
they lives where they were exposed to I
mean you know inhuman conditions this is
this is the material of so much of 19th
century literature and you know I
actually came to those experiences
largely through two novels largely
through reading 19th century literature
whether it's slow bear or there is
Dickens or Zola or Balzac this is the
experience they are they are talking
about the vast large scale up rootedness
and we began to think that modernization
was a benign process and so I think
especially since the end of the Cold War
we have lived with a lot of illusions
and they're just broken right now with
the United States itself with Western
Europe itself the sort of originator of
the modern world of modernity its ideas
its principles rejoining this this is
very tormented history so not just this
book but your previous book from the
ruins empire that was a in intellectual
history of modern Asia or more
specifically the attempt of certain
thinkers in Asia to
create a modern historical intellectual
narrative that could counter the
dominant narrative of the West so there
that's a counter narrative to the
Western narrative of progress now in
this book the second counter narrative
to the Western narrative of progress
you mentioned fraudulent history I think
it's called I mean at this point should
we really regard the Western notion of
progress as fraudulent history that we
need to do away with what does I think
you know progress is the facts but it's
always patchy is uneven it's a result of
a confluence of different factors not
all of them have to do with capitalism
or democracy we tend to give too much
credit to these you know abstractions we
cherish and we love but problems
whenever it is made it's a result of you
know very many disconcerting conferences
you know the fact that women's rights
were advanced most of all by the two
world wars we tend to think of progress
that's happening because economic growth
is happening and the middle classes are
demanding certain rights and and and so
there's a big package of rights going
through unfortunately that's not how
history is worked that progress of
always being on patchy and uneven so
basing a whole narrative of universal
progress on this very complex
paradoxical story
really does make you think there's
something fraudulent about this this
notion that we're all you know the
kingdom of God is about to be recreated
on on on on earth and the people I
described in my previous book who were
challenging this particular narrative
they were again not challenging it in
isolation many of them especially after
the first world war were drawing upon
and in many cases echoing the
conclusions increasingly reached at that
time by Europeans
by some of the best European writers and
philosophers after the first world war
that was the moment of reckoning for so
many of them with ideas of progress and
again examining assumptions in the way
you know a lot of us are trying to do
now is like what was this world we were
dreaming about you know what was this
great narrative it is Henry James or or
Musa lore or TS Eliot's they're all
questioning this this particular
narrative that so many people had
believed in that the 19th century is all
this century about irreversible
unstoppable progress and someone like to
go or Gandhi who are challenging this
narrative they're also drawing from
Western sources I mean Gandhi is
inconceivable without someone like
Ruskin or someone like Tolstoy who can
see the violence of this this process of
modernization and and is writing about
it so you know in a way we've all kind
of inhabited this particular framework
of the modern responded to it seeing its
inadequacies its Falls and and written
about it and those ideas those critiques
have traveled widely they've been shared
widely I do think that the last two
three years have been an exceptional
period of intellectual parochialism of a
certain kind of homogenized narrative
emanating from some of the elite centers
of education disseminated by a newspaper
editorials I mean just basically
informing assumptions whether in
speeches by politicians or policymaking
and they've all been informed by this
sort of this great master narrative
that's you know progress is happening
and it's all working out you only have
to adopt these particular models of
capitalism and and democracy and things
will work out in the way it has worked
out for us so
I want to talk about anger but your
reference to the kingdom of God makes me
ask as I understand it tell me if I've
got that's right so with the decline of
religion in Western societies their
religion was replaced by the sub
religion of nationalism in some respects
and the religion of ideology or where
there was communism or some other form
of totalitarianism in other respects but
what you're really bringing to the fore
is how this third sub religion emerged
the religion of progress sub religion of
progress and we're only now seeing that
the illusory qualities of that of that
belief but is the great unbeatable
religion really I mean in a way it
seduces it makes people discard their
critical intellectual faculties I mean I
think you know we know that religion and
in Christianity in particular has been
marked by doubt at least since Pascal
but progress the religion of progress
does not admit those doubts so in a way
it's more hardline than man 10 most
religions and it's also you know deeply
deeply persuasive especially if you stop
believing which is the case for for for
most of us today in any other form of
transcendental Authority then your
horizons are basically defined by
progress and the simple belief that the
future would be better for your children
and for your grandchildren and things
are going to get better and better all
the time which has been the experience
again it has been the experience of many
people since 1945 this is not an
experience that people say in the first
half of 20th century could have had they
could not if you are living through the
civil war in China you could not have
imagined a better future for your
children oil or your grandchildren but
hundreds of millions of people since
9:00
have believed that things are getting
better all the time and their belief is
grounded in certain realities that
progress has happened but again that is
you know it turns out that was a that
was this moment in in in in the long
sweep of time which is now ended and
that we are looking at a completely
different reality altogether so this is
why it's an age of anger you've got
hundreds of millions of people who have
glimpsed the promise of progress who
have had some contact with in their own
lives they have a vision of what
progress supposedly represents conveyed
through the media but that they run up
against the lack of actual progress in
their own lives and their own societies
and and are angry I think I mean it is
you know it is a case of extravagant
expectation thinking that the privileges
for instance in this part of the world
that you have enjoyed for decades now
are going to continue forever well not
with globalization not with the Chinese
joint the global economy with the large
labor force then if you are in India
thinking that you will have one day the
life promised to you by everything
around you billboards in small towns
television the internet house with two
cars and a garage that is not going to
be the reality the the realized promise
of most people in that country so in one
instance you have the fear of downward
mobility then in other places where
people have been taken out of extreme
poverty and now find themselves or find
their their path ahead blocked so that
is a case of blocks mobility and at some
point the accumulated frustrations
become politically toxic and that is
what has happened I think in the last
few years
that we've been promised a lot we've
been promised a lot by the ideologies of
progress which as I said are broadcast
from from all different directions and
we find that most of these promises are
unfulfillable they're certainly not
being fulfilled and it's quite likely
the unfulfillable for one we have now
very serious environmental constraints
we've already seen the political risks
of unfulfillable promises and now you
have you know some the simple fact that
the planet doesn't have enough resources
to bring billions of Indians and Chinese
to to the same level that's a few people
in Europe and America have been on four
for four for a few decades but then this
anger is more general than it's not
confined to people in the developed
developing world so-called who aren't
going to be able to live the way people
live in Washington DC it seems to run
right up to the top where people in the
middle and upper middle class in this
country who are extravagant wealth by
global standards are still prone to the
same anger and resentment that that is
that you're also seeing in Nigeria and
in India and Indonesia
this is why it's an age of anger is
right absolutely I mean I think in a
world which is run by or is supposed to
run by this ideal by this reality of
comparison of constantly comparing
yourself to the lives of other people to
the well-being and and contentment of
other people and thinking that you're
missing out that you're lacking
something what other people have and
then also the fear that whatever you
have might be taken away from you that
you might lose it those kinds of
emotions are prevalent universally today
because we live in a global society that
is supposed to be driven by
terrorism by vanity by status seeking by
well seeking and when you find that
actually this is a you know incredibly
unequal society where opportunities are
horribly unevenly distributed and even
then those who have at this point start
to be victims to the same fears and
anxieties as the have-nots and this is
what we're seeing today the how the have
also have in addition to economic
inequality they might also have other
problems which is that even though they
have money their wealth but they don't
have access to intellectual and cultural
capital which is certainly the case with
our plutocratic president who is really
incredibly neurotic it seems about the
cultural power possessed by Manhattan
liberals for instance and it is
constantly baiting them and targeting
the New York Times so those that there
are those kinds of resentments also at
work where people feel that a tiny elite
has monopolized intellectual and
cultural capital
it was to be striking to see Rene Girard
show up in the middle of this argument
most of the thinkers in the book are
from the 18th 19th and first part of the
20th century and in Europe and suddenly
Girard a Frenchman who wound up teaching
at Stanford and died only last year
contributes a key idea the idea of
memetic rivalry can you explain that oh
it's really a notion that lit up a whole
landscape for me sure are himself did
not really extend his theory of memetic
rivalry to say geopolitics or or or
history but this notion that what we
desire is mediated through the desires
of other people that suddenly made me
think about much of modern history as
essentially an incredibly intense game
of emulation where a small minority
achieves extraordinary amounts of power
and wealth and cultural sophistication
and then the rest want to catch up they
want those things for themselves and
this process then spreads all around the
world in a kind of escalated fashion if
it has an existential basis which you
bring out very powerfully there's
something that's more the material want
that that people are after when they
imitate others the it's the being that
the other person seems to have yes very
much so it's it's it's a it's a
unappeasable existential envy and and
desire this person seems more alive or
more fulfilled or more participant in
the life of society than I am because
that person has a better house a better
car a better job or better real estate
and
that's why I wanted not just have better
an but to be to have more being
absolutely and you know someone who then
illustrated this syndrome perfectly I
thought was Russo in the late 18th
century very very kind of identified
nemesis or mimetic rivalry as a source
of a serious spiritual deformity and as
actually something that prevents
individuals from enjoying inner freedom
so very early on as this commercial
society premised on vanity on on
imitation is coming into being here's a
man saying ok there are some serious
internal contradictions here which will
leave most human beings deeply unhappy
and frustrated because this particular
desire to shine to compete with others
to achieve more than other people is
kind of unappeasable it's unfulfillable
and what it will also do is is is make
individuals feel happy when they
dominate others that domination would
become a kind of ideal secretly in
seriously so I think Gerard and others
you know identified certain pathologies
which you know have kind of assumed
political forms today and and again you
know they had assumed political forms in
the past and led to all kinds of
incredibly bloody competitive wars and
conflicts now at least you know they're
relatively controlled we're still seeing
them exploding within particular
national context we are at least not
faced with a repeat of the destructive
Wars for instance that we saw in the
first half of 2010
all driven by this competitive instinct
to have what others of course I mean
what is the what does the history of
Germany illustrate which is this
fanatical desire to catch up with
Britain and France to beat them at their
own game to accumulate the same kind of
political economic and military power
that they seem to possess at least today
you know those kinds of limited
rivalries don't seem to be erupting into
another major war I think but
nevertheless you know the conflict we
are faced with right now is is serious
and it's in its own line these passions
these emotions in this narrative that
you set out take root again and again in
this figure that you call the alienated
young man of promise the alienated young
man of promise who appears in all
modernizing countries speaks on behalf
of the illiterate majority the educated
minority or himself myself that turns
out to be painfully divided in all cases
he articulates a profound sense of
inadequacy and tries to draw an
ambitious blueprint to overcome it but
this improvised program of belief and
action cannot be neatly mapped under the
classifications of ideas and movements
of the broad sectarian categories of
left and right liberal conservatives
that commonly mediate our understanding
of history and current affairs is this
alienated young man of promise this is a
figure you've encountered in your
reporting over the world absolutely and
also since I started out as a novelist
my unit of analysis has always been this
divided human being and one reason you
know why I specified very clearly that I
do not really want to talk about my
subject in these categories of left and
rights liberal and conservative or use
that a degree of class
to describe this broad span of history I
wanted to stay focused on the on the
individual and as I said I encountered
this nineteenth-century individual true
through to fiction through true
literature and I wanted to show how this
person is deeply deeply internally
divided so this is not a coherent being
we cannot simply take the claims that
this person makes whether it's a claim
for liberalism or socialism or or
nationalism at face value that we have
to examine what exactly this person is
suffering from and that was you know
really what I what I wanted to do in
this book then to simply assume this
person is on the left or this person
will to the right this person is a
liberal or this person is a conservative
based on what they say about themselves
and about their aims and about their
their their their intentions which meant
that you know a whole lot of
conventional history really interest in
at least in the way I look at it
basically sets off these abstractions
against each other without ever taking
into account this this concrete human
being with his existential fears and
anxieties and desires and I think in a
way someone likes Gerar or or Rousseau
really helped me and although you know I
think someone like Gandhi was very alert
to to this to this particular divided
figure and evolved the whole politics a
whole way of being in the world and of
doing politics on the basis of this
divided human being
still I think you know in the way we
have done history and the way we have
done intellectual history we haven't
really taken on board the insights
of literature into this human individual
and uh you know this is this is a book
that would be inconceivable without the
help it has got from novelists and poets
you visited Orhan Pamuk a couple of
years ago and I think of him as someone
who has that same strong attention to
the 19th century as prefiguring some of
the patterns that we see in the present
he'll write a novel like snow that makes
explicit reference to Dostoyevsky but
applies the situation in Russia and then
to the situation in Turkey in recent
times exist did you get a talk about
this this kind of thing with him we did
we did I mean I think you know whenever
people from the so-called Left Behind
Nations get together there's always a
lot to discuss about these issues
because you realize that at a very
fundamental level there are a whole set
of experiences that link us the feeling
of primarily the feeling of being left
behind of our elites thinking that we
have to catch up we have to do something
and then of course the feeling of
confronting the superior civilization
and feeling intimidated by its feeling
scorn by it
Dostoevsky is a sort of you know in many
ways both describes and enacts this
syndrome in its in its fiction you can
think of any number of Japanese not less
and of course Palmer is and that is in
that particular tradition in fact before
this before I started writing this book
I've been taking notes for a book which
was going to be primarily about Left
Behind nations so we're trying to
construct the kind of taxonomy of these
countries and the peoples and their
particular literature's who share
certain very important features whether
you are
Egyptian writer or Indian writer or or a
Chinese writer there are certain
resemblances and immediate recognitions
there so I think that again came in very
handy all the notes I've taken for the
story of the Left Behind people's when
it turned out that there were lots of
people left behind in the heart of the
modern West who also manifested some of
these traits of Rahsaan Timor again that
sort of freedom great essential envy and
resentment that's depending on
circumstances these feelings and
emotions can arise in completely
unexpected contexts if you know the loss
of power the prospect of economic
decline can induce those feelings and
emotions in in the richest and the most
powerful country in the world so you
speak about you and Palmer talking about
being belonging to the Left Behind
Nations and yet he's got a Nobel Prize
you live in London and have a list of
prizes as long as my arm when you
describe that alienate that man of
promise and his division sometimes
speaking for the dispossessed sometimes
speaking for the elite sometimes
speaking for himself it seems there are
some sideways self portraiture there
what is it can you talk about your
multiple social location and and how you
identify yourself well I suppose since I
did not really have access to a whole
set of experiences that are I suppose
taken for granted by you know people in
power wherever you are whether you're in
India or China because I grew up in
really small places in India and belong
to it's not quite accurate to Skol it's
no little flowers but somewhere there
somewhere in some way in those levels
and so it was a very different
experience of the world where some of
the feelings I described in the book
were widely shared amongst people that I
grew up with people I went to college
with the kind of result email for
instance mr. Modi has done so
politically potent in India I grew up
with that kind of resulting more of the
local Anglophone elites who seem to be
feathering the nest while speaking of
democracy and progress and freedom
people who had monopolized all cultural
and intellectual capital and and scorned
people who do not him who did not have
access to it
Modi has turned that to great advantage
this particular version of class
conflicts in India by railing against
this this corrupts and arrogant elite
and he has found lots of people who
believe that his rights and he is right
to a certain extent so it was easier to
me for me to understand his his appeal
because I was one of those people who
had felt those emotions in the past and
I had certainly spent a lot of time with
people who were who were who were who
accept those emotions were feeling those
emotions and that I that I feel as given
me a kind of access to the alienated
stranger the provincial outsider who we
tend to neglect in our intellectual
journalistic discourses and as we now
see who has become politically extremely
extremely powerful with these recent
elections the sort of semi rural semi
urban
inhabitant who did not feature much in
our in our in our conversations who had
been in a way simmering with with all
kinds of rage and frustration and now we
see this figure all around us
books are being written about about this
figure journalist new journalist
articles are being are being
commissioned but I think you know what
it is pointing to all this new interest
is this extraordinary absence in our in
our in our kind of discourse all this
time and I feel like we really need to
pay more attention to the loser's of
history we've been too obsessed with the
winners and in a way you know this book
really is an attempt to describe those
losses of history and what they do when
losing becomes intolerable who was in
this industry is written by the winners
sit who was it it becomes almost a kind
of truism that's hard to manage from its
author yeah yeah but this is an attempt
to write history with a greater
attention to the seeming losers in this
in economic terms anyway the last 40 50
60 years you link up Timothy McVeigh and
ramzi yousef at crucial point of the
book and that link becomes really
suggestive for the way different kinds
of angry people in different cultures
have more in common than then we might
expect can you explain well I mean this
is another way of talking about you know
how these theories about the clash of
civilizations all this idea that people
belonging to different religious
communities are bound to enter into
conflict with each other and they don't
really share much any number of examples
historically and in the present
mcveigh's friendship with rom the use of
is one example
so they were in joining cells in prison
prison and new mexico super Supermax
facility and and and discovered each
other and became great friends and
realized that they had a lot in common
politically to the point where McVeigh
said he believed in what use of them and
then subsequently who saw bin Laden was
doing and that they were right to do
what they did now that kind of meeting
of minds that kindness intellectual
ideological affinity we see over and
over again we don't want to notice it
you know brave ik the Norwegian mass
murderer he's fascinated by by by Hindu
fanatics he wanted to get into alliances
with fit into fanatics against
multiculturalism the man the young boy a
teenager I think who kills nine or ten
people in Munich last year Iranian
Iranian German he was inspired by
braving any any number of such instances
where you know these affinities are
crossing religious national borders and
what they are pointing to is a kind of
shared temperament again that sort of
you know divided selves and driven by
rage and frustration into extreme acts
of violence identifying certain targets
where there is multiculturalists or
liberals or or or the states of the
American state in this instance and I do
think we have to you know going back to
your are think about the world today is
constituted by sameness rather than
difference constituted by increasing
similarity of experience of emotion of
ideas rather than say oh no this is all
this all began when because Christians
started fighting Muslims you know back
during the Crusades this is all a
residue of those ancient enmities and
and battles we really have to look at
how these ideas and ideologies travel
how they're absorbed in in you know
different context and and turn to
different users when we swapped emails
last summer one of us said to the other
we have to talk about Pope Francis and
then I see him referenced in the book as
the most influential public on actual
today and in ways that where he's seen
as lining up persuasively with some of
your most important points can you
explain that well I think you know very
superficially here's a man with enormous
moral authority representing an
institution that's you know the most
oldest venerable institutions in the
world today who dares to speak of
charity in a time when we've all become
you know and I include myself in that
category I include individuals not just
you know people that I don't disagree
with politically we've all become
possessive we've all started to define
ourselves in in exclusive ways and with
particular nations with particular ideas
and ideologies here is a man who comes
at the end of a very long phase of
relative peace and stability and things
are starting to fall apart and he's
still talking about how charity is the
way out how so many of our foundational
ideas and concepts lying tatters today
and the only way in which we can escape
this rampant destruction is through acts
of charity and through through acts of
compassion you know the Knotts
intellectual life in the way it has been
institutionalized and professionalized
has had very little space for this kind
of discourse or this kind of
conversation there was a time when
certain kind of religiously motivated
thinker was still central to the culture
kneeboard is one example of that MLK
another one but we haven't had that kind
of figure who speaks that kind of employ
that kind of model essentially moral
vocabulary otherwise what is public
intellectualism you know it's become
essentially regurgitated
the ideology of the day maybe
disagreeing with it to a certain extent
but you know essentially the assumptions
are broadly shared by you know the the
so-called public intellectuals and you
know we are struggling all of us are
struggling to make sense of what is
happening today
I don't think Pope Francis is struggling
to make sense of what is happening today
he has been warning about it for some
time what do you think is there anything
to be done the tentative anger it's
global things are getting worse the
anger that people feel is perfectly
justified because society is unfair and
getting worse in so many ways what what
should we do well
here's where I could suppose going to
business as a guru with my Indian
background and beer you know I think
some you know personally I feel that as
a writer all I can do is is challenge
myself more and more and and just work
harder but you know if were to prescribe
anything I would to other people I would
actually would say that look it's
actually these prescriptions that were
supposed to work University that have
got us into this mess
and that whatever solutions we work
towards they have to be contingent on
our particular circumstances wherever we
are in the world today there are certain
you know broad principles I think the
fact that so many people have become
politicized overnight in the last few
weeks and have realized how high the
stakes are
suddenly for themselves for the children
for the grandchildren and become engaged
with politics with you know just
everything that's happening around the
world today that is a great sign
and I think solutions would emerge from
this experience of greater knowledge
greater solidarity and impose feelings
of trust and compassion that have to
accompany this kind of this kind of
politics otherwise I think the days of
broad overarching solutions are over and
quite rightly and I think we should
celebrate that in a way that this crisis
this disaster around us is forcing us to
ask some hard questions and think again
about the shape of our societies the
shape of our ideologies that itself is a
sort of you know a way in which we can
fumble grasp our way towards workable
solutions amen to that
it's thrilling to have you here and hear
your answers to questions that I've been
forming as I've gone through the book
now I want to open open things up to
questions from members of the audience
the microphones are in the center and if
you have a question someone will give a
microphone to you and directed upon Kosh
ah thank you so much for just such an
enlightening conversation I was thinking
when you were mentioning the medic
rivalry and this pursuit of happiness
which of course is embedded even in the
American Declaration of Independence it
does that mean that there is a
pathological flaw in our founding
documents here which then perhaps augers
this kind of memetic rivalry it's it's
sort of built into our bloodstream I
mean so it's really a question that can
be answered in all kinds of different
ways one is of course the contradiction
that opens up in the individuals soul
when you enter into this race for status
and and wealth and end up rejoicing in
the domination of other people or
rejoicing in the humiliation objection
of other people that is a contradiction
that you know lots of people have talked
about the other contradiction is that
the ideas of freedom are formulated by
members of a minority who simply assume
that that freedom is not going to be
available to people who are not like
them to to to slaves for instance to
Native Americans same we have on the
other side of the Atlantic people have
already made assumptions who's human and
who isn't who is deserving of freedom
and who isn't so in many ways we are
looking at a civilization of a minority
whose principles are formulated by a
minority for themselves how does how do
we extend those ideas admirable as they
are to the vast majority that one
to realize them that is the question
we've been struggling with since the
advent of the modern world that is a
course of modern history the Russian
writer who's been a huge influence on
the Alexander Hertz and I quote in the
book saying after long experience of
Europe that you know what he has seen
there is a civilization of the minority
where the masses are uninvited guests at
the feast of life who have to be either
excluded or suppressed and that in many
ways anew remains at least the
experience of a lot of people and of
course you know what we think today are
the feelings of rage that are generated
by this experience of exclusion and
suppression
your analysis is quite profound of the
problem I'd like you to talk a little
more about without being a GU about
solutions even in you know abstract
terms I'm struck by your praise of Pope
Francis from acts of charity but of
course he's not a political person he's
political person but he's not a
politician and some of the people you
praised like Marvel's King jr. like
Gandhi were not politicians but they're
very political and they they organized
movements political and social movements
and seems to me that the problem we have
is partly caused by politics bad
politics divisive politics and I'm
afraid I guess that without some
overarching sense of movements and and
based on values that that the older more
partial kinds of politics would take
over which they already are taking over
you know fundamentals religion
aggressive nationalism and so forth as
no racial populism so I just like to
push you a little bit on that you know
what about politics
to make it short well I think you know
people like Martin Luther King and
Gandhi are interesting figures in that
they try to marry spiritual projects
religious projects with political
activism and what they realize is that
whole range of human needs and
aspirations are not being met by
politics as practiced that politics have
become you know too determined by
certain pursuits that were deemed
essential the pursuit of happiness the
pursuit of happiness through the pursuit
of wealth and pursuit of status and
that's caused deep divisions within
society that caused people to think in
hyper individualistic ways neglecting
other human needs such a solidarity
community feeling of you know belonging
to a particular group and acting in
unison with other people all these needs
were being systematically neglected by
modern politics and an economy and so
their attempt was to you know combine
politics with spirituality in a way that
those needs are met and at the same time
a very distinct very clearly defined
political agenda is also advanced at the
same time and I think you know when I
think of solutions maybe this is to
anti-intellectual of me this is what I
this is what I imagine this is what I
think that we have to reconsider a
solidarity and sense of community
otherwise it's the right thing
demagogues who are going to offer faith
clarity and solidarity to the aggrieved
and it is affected and triumph and they
how they can offer solidarity by saying
well let's exclude of a lot of people
and demonize a whole lot of people and
that can become the basis of of
solidarity so in a way you know I think
they have very kindly included that a
lot of people suffering today are
actually in dire need of these
communities you know what we call people
or what we dismiss as people in echo
chambers or or you know little Facebook
communities but this is the kind of
perverted expression of a longing for
community and a longing for identity
that's I think the left or liberals have
been blind to Dorothy Day the founders
of the cup worker was against the New
Deal and the reason she was against the
New Deal is a Catholic anarchist was
that it corporated the state
appropriated the doing of good works and
systematized and bureaucratized it and
she thought that the solution really had
love and the caring of people for one
another that was spontaneous and freely
offered person-to-person and that idea
sounds truly strange today I think but
that's something like what you're
suggesting yeah yeah
thank you very much for an absolutely
illuminating talk I was really struck I
haven't read the book yet and I can't
wait to get my hands on it but I was
really struck by the way in which
religion seems to be sort of haunting a
lot of this project because your art
theory is actually really about
sacrificial violence and in that sense
thinking about my magic rivalry is
deeply depressing in this context
because for him there's no catharsis we
will continue to escape codes and the
rival will become monstrous and there's
no end to violence but on your thinking
about another trajectory of the sacred
and going back to people like Gandhi on
his appropriation of really puppy
practice as a new form of political
practice or MLK or Pope Francis today
and so I'm thinking about the Serve
debate for example Gandhi has with
ambassador right we're relying on the
notion that Duffy has a way of being is
going to actually really transform
society so that the vast majority of
marginalised can suddenly live well and
on base cares deep cynicism but that
could ever be the case and that you have
to rely on sort of the legal processes
of the state to protect people are we
back there now are we rehashing the same
problem and then if so then how do we
not fall into the same impasse yeah I
think for those of you who do not know
about this great debates between
Ambedkar and Gandhi a very shortened
version of that is that Gandhi as you
correctly characterizes his position
thought of this notion of devotion as
creating the conditions in which
equality and the end to discrimination
could be achieved and ambach was a sort
of at least in that phase in his life as
a classic modernist thinking of the
state like many people at that time you
know he was like all of us he was a
creature of his time
and then again you know trusting in the
state to enforce equality and of course
there are examples of the state doing
that most notoriously in China where
women's rights were achieved by brutal
dictate from from above I think you know
that debate continues that debates can
be had but the state has altered you
know the state is no longer the social
democratic state that someone like
Ambedkar simply assumed would be around
the state has changes its characters
everywhere whether post-colonial India
or or Europe and indeed here so we can't
really expect too much too much from the
state at this point we can't even expect
too much from political parties
political party apparatus which are
completely dysfunctional right now
unable to harness any political energy
and this is the case again everywhere
you see that in Europe we see that here
although there are insurgent movements
here and there like Bernie Sanders's but
on the whole you know the kind of
institutionalized politics has become
unresponsive in a really very depressing
depressing way but I think Gandhi in his
distrust of abstractions is a great line
in Dwight MacDonald's obituary of Gandhi
again a very unlikely Gandhi was an
unlikely hero also poor Dorothy Day and
also for Dwight McDonald's who said I
love the man because he never gave big
speeches about progress and and freedom
and liberty he was focused on the
everyday on the small things of life and
I think you know God Lee did not talk
about these things because he saw them
as essentially kind of beguiling
illusions
and what he was focused on that you know
basically these things are meaningless
these are meaningless slogans and in the
end you have to deal with individuals
you have to deal with flesh-and-blood
human beings and he also feared adding a
side of him the kind of nihilism that
could be unleashed by the shattering of
faith in these abstractions and we are
seeing some of that today that the
substitute religion will fail and well
before that happens is best to introduce
these ideals and these disciplines into
politics so I think you know that was is
that was his project not depending on
the on the state or not depending on
conventional political parties or
processes but depending on individual
transformation an individual persuasion
and dialogue
hi I had a question so you talked a lot
about how in the 19th century a lot of
the the books that you read uh when
you're growing up where how you came to
these ideas and how you understood them
and a lot of scholars of nationalism
recognized the role of men capitalism of
literature in disseminating ideas of
nationalism and sort of expressing the
feeling of resentment that you're
talking about do you see any parallels
from the 19th century and that type of
literature with the 21st century and
with the Internet in the way that a lot
of different movements of national
movements have moved online and have
been moving in a way that hasn't really
been looked at and how they're using
those platforms to sort of frame their
movements thank you thank you well I
suppose the Internet is essential to our
culture now in the way the novel was
central to 19th century cultures in in
Europe in that that is where new
communities are being formed new
solidarities are being created
constructed and speed you know with
which this happens is is quite
staggering you know in the days of 19th
century in the days of you know print
books things happen relatively slowly as
they this they were still confined to
the literate public so we are talking
about a small minority of people who
were leading nationalist movements or
our defining the national idea or the
national community now it can happen
more or less over lights so 20th century
in that sense you know the 20 century
fiction writer finds himself ourself in
a very strange place because he or she
is no longer central to the culture that
place has been taken and it's also true
that
the ninety this is another discussion
but the post 45 novel it would be you
would be hard-pressed to draw from it
the kind of historical lessons and
philosophical insights you could draw
from any number of 19th century writers
and it's an angel is interesting to to
to compare the two and see what happens
you know what were the big sociological
shifts to make this you know to make do
to do to render the 19th century novels
so important and the 21st century novel
so marginal but you know that's that's a
different discussion are there
exceptions is a book like fine balance
20th century novel just lacking in the
power of its 19th century predecessors
or are there are there people who are
putting it together and well the fine
violence I mean you know is in the
classic nineteenth-century novel just
have to be written in a very exactly
like you know you um and you know
there's nothing in it about and they
can't be since it's set in a different
era altogether about the world we
inhabit today which is being transformed
so dramatically so speedily that it's
really hard for anyone to keep up let
alone a novelist who works over you know
at a minimum three or four years
that's what sell abroad said in 1962 so
if if that's the case then no fiction of
social consequence or whatever you want
to call it has happened in our lifetime
well I think no I wouldn't go that far I
think what I'm saying is that fiction
19th century fiction in the way bothered
guides and remains a guide to 19th
century societies their particular
politics that attitudes you could learn
a lot about how the Paris Stock Exchange
for instance works by reading Balzac
you could under you know at a
superficial level of information if
you're interested in the big
philosophical debate of the 19th century
it's easy enough to go to Tolstoy and
Dostoyevsky and read them to find the
central debate after all I mean someone
like me che old so much to figure like
Dostoyevsky so even philosophers are
people we because philosophers are
reading the novelist of the 19th century
and being stimulated by them it's hard
to think of I mean also I suppose
because philosophy today has a very
different role it's quite it's very
marginal today so it wouldn't have the
same kind of relationship with fiction
but it's really hard to imagine a book
as meaningful in all kinds of ways as
say the Brothers Grimm Azov or war and
peace I mean I know these are unfair
comparisons in many ways but you could
also look at a small book like notes
from the underground which featured a
lot in this book and to take readings of
particular psychologies particular
temperaments in the way that did the
19th century novelist did I just don't
know whether that is possible in our
much more diverse much more fragmented
societies today let's take a novel that
I know that we both really admire I
remember when the biography of nightfall
came out we talked about it and you said
rightly you know it's a decent book but
it really didn't explain how that man
wrote a bend in the river so that's a
novel it's not about the president but
it's the past 25 years that can you
imagine someone looking back on the best
of thy fall and and an understanding
this world of ideas in the culture at
that time through the novel the way we
look back on Duff deskey I suppose they
could but again I mean I think you you
would not think of that novel again as
breaking new ground philosophically it
would not eliminate in many ways the
bend of the river you could argue is an
updated version of notes from the
underground you're talking about a man
half a ja'kayden man who finds himself
in a Indian in this instance who find
themselves in a part of Africa and in a
very fraught political context which
also you can find in in many other
novels and sometimes much more acutely
done the local politics of it but the
existential aspects of the novel that I
don't think are particularly unique you
could find examples of that all across
the 90 the setting is interesting that
the bringing together of the setting and
this particular this alienated stranger
and outsider in this particular setting
that is interesting that is something
new but I'm not sure whether that would
stand as a a panoramic account of that
part of Africa he was saying two things
one is that that novel owes more to its
predecessors it's in its got a lot of
inheritance - my Paul himself says that
that the novel is finished because the
big moment was in the nineteenth century
and we been repeating ourselves so he
actually admits - there's a lack of
originality but also that there's a
philosophical dimension a way in which
ideas are just are
tossed and turned in the great 19th
century novels in a way that we're not
used to seeing in fiction today where
Ivan careless off will go on a discourse
about theodicy or Tolstoy has his in
dust asking as his George Eliot has hers
that's what's not what not there that
access easy access to ideas
he says his ideas and also the
experiences of fresh in the 19th century
I mean I think we may blame the novelist
today for not being alert enough and so
on so forth which many people do I think
is unfair because what the novelists in
the 19th century was describing was a
moment of transformation that he was
sheen were actually living through were
intimately part of it and those
experience were happening to many people
for the first time in history the
experience of urbanization for instance
was happening for the first time now
today when novels are written about
urbanization in India or rural
immigrants like fine balance you can you
know the one of the pleasures of reading
fictions like that is the memory that
constantly haunts you of the novels
you've read previously of set in the
nineteenth century is also the trail of
familiarity yeah I mean there's also a
sense in which the nineteenth-century
novel was developing technically in the
way society was developing technically
there's a sense of discovery and of
breakthroughs in art that correspondent
to the steam engine and rail and
electric light and so forth that were
not Don DeLillo said about novels today
we make our riddle leaks but the
emphasis is on little there's this
smaller area of innovation now probably
in fiction
a question well first of all great
takling is really articulate and logical
supported by historical examples but
there are people who don't even know
like most of the words you've said today
like let alone understand them so like
you mentioned like earlier you know
they're divided families there are
people that are led by their emotions
regardless of their circumstances and I
kind of I kind of feel that way
sometimes where I feel like I'm for
example like the New York Times and the
person I'm talking to is Donald Trump
and I wanted to ask like how do you how
you facilitate a dialogue between people
like that like or with people like that
like how do you dumb down this material
or should you or like does it lose
something when you like dumb down all of
these like really important arguments
that you're making yeah um I don't know
whether it's my role to have a you know
dialogue as it were with people on the
other side and also I don't think that
on the other side you know we are as I
keep saying we are all inhabiting the
same space the same ground these
divisions are essentially mental mental
constructions so you know I can talk
about this book and it's in its content
in a in a particular kind of language
when I go back to India to this place
where I've spent most of my adult life
there's a different language in which I
speak about the issues and I don't see
why I have to dumb down anything because
you know these people
who I'm speaking to have the benefit of
long experience of these realities that
I'm writing about in fact I am
plagiarizing from the experience and I'm
stealing the experiences
so it's me for anyone who's dumping it
down really you know I'm the one guilty
of that so I think you know one of the
ways in which we can transcend this this
the sort of the the great conflicts and
and and divisions of our overtime is by
you know not really I mean trying to
examine trying to think of these
divisions as essentially constructions
that we ourselves have have created and
learning to recognize wisdom and
experience in places far outside our
circles and in our particular groups and
the abilities to identify them to talk
about them meaningfully I feel like that
is something as I which as we were
discussing earlier has been lacking in a
lot of journalistic discourse that it
has been too much it has been about the
winners it has not really talked about
the losers and we need to refocus
attention on them we have time for one
more question
your another question
I'm still trying to understand the
limits that you put on the idea of
progress
you're talking about if I understood it
correctly social progress and your
skepticism about social progress I can
understand but I have difficulty in
reconciling it with economic progress
with the fact that we've been able to
overcome such poverty in the 21st
century in many areas of the world the
fact that child birth now is much less
difficult must much less fraught with
the dangers that have been bought by
modern medicine so I guess what I'm
asking is do you see the same type of
skepticism in economic progress as you
do in social I think this is a you know
I mean it's a it's a minefield of a
subject anyone who's had a who sat in
the dentist's chair and had local
anesthetic applied and then still felt
sore afterwards must be grateful to
modern medicine for the progress it has
made in the time not so long ago when
anesthetic had not been invented and
operations really serious
life-threatening operations had to be
done without it so of course you know
there is progress of that kind economic
progress it's a much more complicated
issue than it seems from these
quantitative measures you know mortality
childbirth people being lifted out of
out of out of poverty when we make those
assessments we actually don't often then
see what happens to people and they're
lifted out of poverty and what is this
poverty line anyway I mean you know
quite apart from the fact that measure
themselves are shifting variable
certainly not solid dependent very much
contingent on who is making them at what
time I can speak from my own experience
again of individuals who I have seen
leave the village where I've spent most
of my adult life in search of better
opportunities in in big cities kind of
classic move from the village to the big
city where they are certainly earning
money of the kind that they could have
previously only dreamed of so not only
have they been lifted above kind a
statistical level of poverty they are
almost in a kind of World Bank in West
World Bank estimates at a lower
middle-income group but then life has
suffered a dramatic collapse in it's in
it's in actually living standards the
fact that they are living in a horribly
polluted city in a slum whatever money
they are making does not entitle them to
anything more than a room a roof above
the head and sometimes you know have to
sleep in the open if you're doing jobs
like taxi taxi driving and that sort of
thing people simply sleep in the open or
with a tarpaulin roof so that kind of
alienated existence where you're making
money but you can't afford you're
working 14 hours a day you can't afford
to have your family there you can't
afford to start a family you're away
from your parents I've seen people
recoil from that experience and come
back and retreats go below the poverty
line again because a whole lot of things
that were important to them that made
the life meaningful was not available to
them when they moved above the poverty
line so what I'm trying to say is that
these quantitative measures that we use
to assess progress are very deceptive
again they are leaving out a whole range
of human experience a whole range of
human needs that are important that are
vital and for many people
you know they'd simply don't want to be
part of this particular adventure of
economic progress so many people I say
they're very much content to do their
small businesses few errands here and
there farm a little bit and be generally
idle they don't want to be part of the
adventure of endless growths and endless
consumption and I think we forgotten
that oil consists of all kinds of people
who don't subscribe to our ideologies
the ideologies of educated people people
who have actually benefited from
progress who are you know essentially
the main beneficiaries of the modern
world ideologies the fact that lots of
people don't want to be part of it and I
think you know a society that honors
these diverse modes of existence our
society that assumes that the good life
is diverse Lee conceived if in my books
a good society not society that insists
that there is only one way to be and
there's only one way to go forward and
which is the way of more growth and
productivity and consumption and more
work and and so on and so forth it
sounds like what you're setting out
could come out of that book you
described about the Left Behind and I
hope you get a chance to write it
because it's mesmerised here you
describe the lives people who forget
about progress don't even want to have
participate in in the ideology of growth
this this has been fantastic I'm so glad
you're here so god you're still going to
be here to talk with us during the
reception and design books if you have a
book to be signed come on up through the
aisle and pankaj is going to sign books
here we're going to have a table and pen
set up here in just a moment thank you
so much it's been a tremendous event and
I'm so grateful to everybody who's been
here especially right before break thank
you very much for coming and thanks
[Applause]